TWENTY NINE AND WE HAVE OUR
HEARING FOR AGING COMMITTEE BUT
WHAT I'M GONNA DO AND I DO NOT
DO KNOW THAT THE GOOD SENATOR
THAT'S HERE TO MAKE A
PRESENTATION HE'S ALREADY HERE
BRIGHTON EARLY- WE'RE GONNA
GIVE IT MAYBE JUST THIRTY MORE
SECONDS TO SEE HOW MANY MORE
MEMBERS CAN COME IN SO THAT WE
CAN HAVE A QUORUM AND START
WITH YOU. THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE ON TIME.
OKAY SAYS THIS IS
GONNA TAKE ME A WHILE STAR
EIGHT NOW. GOOD MORNING AND
WELCOME TO THE JUNE TWENTY
NINTH ASSEMBLY AGING AND LONG
TERM CARE COMMITTEE HEARING WE
ARE HEARING ONE MEASURE THIS
MORNING THAT I SUPPORT AS AS
DOES THE VICE CHAIR. OF OUR
HEARING WILL BE BRIEF BUT
BEFORE WE CAN GET STARTED I
NEED TO INFORM ALL OF OUR
CURRENT PROTOCOLS. DUE TO
ONGOING COVER NINETY SAFETY
CONSIDERATIONS WE ARE REQUIRING
THAT MASKS BE WORN BY ALL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TESTIFYING WEATHER HERE IN THE-
HEARING ROOM OR AT A REMOTE
TESTIMONY SITE. IF YOU DO NOT
HAVE A MASK WE CAN PROVIDE ONE
FOR YOU WE HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT
OPTIONS FOR WITNESS TESTIMONY
TODAY. FOR THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE RAISE
YOUR HAND. AND I WILL ASK YOU
TO APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
AFTER CENTER LAYER PRESENTS HIS
BILL. I WOULD ASK THAT THE
PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE
YOU CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM
ONCE YOU ARE DONE TESTIFYING OR
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT. PLEASE BE
SURE TO LIMIT ELEVATOR USE TO
FOUR PEOPLE AT A TIME. IN
ADDITION TO BEING ABLE TO
TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE HEARING
ROOM WITNESSES CAN MAKE USE OF
OUR REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
LOCATED ON THE NORTH STEPS OF
THE CAPITOL WE ARE ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH THE
POSITION LETTER. PORTAL WITH
INSTRUCTIONS ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE AND YOU CAN FIND THE
EMAIL FOR THE COMMITTEE THERE
AS WELL- FOR DIALING WITNESSES
WE WILL BE USING A MODERATE A
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH WHICH
ANY WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A
BILL. OUR CALL IN NUMBER FOR
WITNESSES IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AND THE PIN NUMBER IS.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN. AGAIN OUR CALL IN NUMBER
FOR WITNESSES IS. 877-692-8957
AND THE PIN NUMBER IS. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN- THE OPERATOR ON THE LINE
WILL GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW TO BE PLACED IN QUEUE BASED
ON WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE THE BILL IF YOU ARE
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE. THIS INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCAST AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE SOUND ISSUES.
K. PLEASE ALSO BE ADVISED THAT
IF YOU ARE A MAIN WITNESSES
PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR S. B.
TWO FIFTY EIGHT YOU WILL REMAIN
ON THE LIVE LINE AND WILL NEED
TO MEET YOURSELF UNTIL YOU ARE
CALLED ON TO SPEAK THERE ARE
ONLY TWO SUPPORT AND TO OPPOSE
WITNESSES PER MEASURE IF YOU'RE
HAVING ANY PROBLEMS OR
CHALLENGES WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT. NINE ONE SIX
THREE ONE NINE THREE NINE NINE
ZERO AND COMMITTEE STAFF WILL
BE THERE TO TRY TO HELP THANK
YOU FOR BEARING WITH US AS WE
IMPLEMENT METHODS TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL
FACE. WITH THAT LET'S CALL ROLL
AND ESTABLISH QUORUM. MADAM
SECRETARY. THIS AREA. PRESIDENT
WELL YOU KNOW FOR HAPPENED HERE
CALDERON THEY'RE LACKING HERE
READ. WHAT THE REVIEW YEAH.
CENTER LEAD YOU'RE WELCOME TO
PRESENT.
SO BUT NOW.
TRANSACTION. FIFTY THOUSAND.
TESTING THAT SOUNDS LIKE THAT'S
IT OKAY WE'RE GOOD THANK YOU.
HOPEFULLY THAT'S THE ONLY HITCH
OF A THE DAY. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT S. B. TWO FIFTY
EIGHT OF IN THE EARLY NINETEEN
NINETIES I HEADED AN AIDS
SERVICE AGENCY AND RANTED AT
THE HEIGHT OF THE EPIDEMIC
BEFORE WE HAD THE DRUG
COCKTAIL. AND AT THE TIME IT
WAS OUR DREAM THAT PEOPLE WOULD
LIVE TO OLD AGE BUT THAT'S NOT
WHAT WAS HAPPENING AT THE TIME
AND WITH THE ADVENT OF THE DRUG
COCKTAIL. AND HIV BECOMING A
MORE CHRONIC ISSUE ISSUE THAT
CHANGED AND SO NOW 50% OF
CALIFORNIANS WITH HIV OR OVER
THE AGE OF FIFTY. AND SO WHAT
THIS BILL DOES. IS ADDS. TO THE
DEFINITION OF GREATEST SOCIAL
NEED- FOR OUR SENIOR PROGRAMS
UNDER THE OLDER AMERICANS ACT
TO INCLUDE CULTURAL OR SOCIAL
ISOLATION CAUSED BY HIV STATUS
AND WHAT IT REALLY MEANS IS
THERE'S A LOT OF OUTREACH AYE.
IT NATURALLY COMING FOM SANTA
CRUZ WHERE EVERYTHING IS
REVERSED IN THE UNIVERSE- I
SERVED. AS THE CITY COUNCIL'S
REPRESENTATIVE TO THE AREA
AGENCY ON AGING AND IN OUR CASE
NORMALLY THE ELECTED OFFICIALS
RENDON IN OUR CASE IT WAS A
NONPROFIT WITH THE SENIORS
RANTED IN THE ELECTED OFFICIALS
WERE ADVISORY TO THE SENIOR SO
I SERVE NINE YEARS. ON THE
DEVICE RECOUNTS ALMOST VERY
FAMILIAR WITH THE PROGRAMS AND
THIS WOULD REALLY SAY THAT
SOCIAL SOCIAL ISOLATION AND
OTHER THINGS CAUSED BY HIV IN
PEOPLE THAT HAVE AGED WOULD BE
ONE OF THE PRIORITY STATUS IS
FOR DOING OUTREACH FOR THE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE FUNDED UNDER
THE OLDER AMERICANS ACT. AND
THERE ARE MANY CATEGORIES NOW
THIS WOULD ADD A NEW CATEGORY
IT'S THIS BILL WAS SUPPORTED
WIDELY. OUR BY AREA AGENCIES ON
AGING- MANY ARE HIV GROUPS
STATE INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
AND- MANY LGBT GROUPS AND TO
HOW IT IS PASSED THE CENTURY
ARE WITHOUT A NO VOTE THUS FAR.
SECOND I AM HERE TO TEST THE
FIRE TAMMY MARTIN FROM A
QUALITY CALIFORNIA AND I KEEP
LOOKING FOR ANOTHER WAY TO SAY
IT WHEN WE'RE ON THE RECORD BUT
HAS ANDERSON FROM THE LET'S
KICK **** AIDS GROUPS SO FAR- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. THANK YOU AS THE. THANK
YOU WILL THE OPERATE IS- IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE OF ANY OF THE
WITNESSES HERE. IF NOT THEN-
OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN
THE LINE FOR SUPPORT- FOR THE
WITNESSES. ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB TWO FIVE
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS. ZERO ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
ONE FILED BY ZERO AND NOW IN
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR WILL GIVE
YOU YOUR LIFE NUMBER OFFLINE IN
A PLACE YOU BACK INTO THE
QUEUE. ONE FILED BY ZERO THANK
YOU. ONE MOMENT MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE A COUPLE QUEUEING UP WITH
OPERATORS. OUR FIRST PART. WILL
COME FROM WIND CAN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE TEN. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN BIRTH CORRECT BOTH
THE FOR ON BEHALF OF A PLS HELP
A PROUD CO SPONSOR IN STRONG
SUPPORT. AND NEXT WE WILL GO
TO. LINE TWELFTH. TWELVE YOUR
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS JENNIFER
PASSED WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK
YOU. OPERATOR ARE THE MAIN
WITNESSES AVAILABLE. I AS
WITNESSES ON THE AIRLINE SHOULD
BE ALREADY OPEN I APOLOGIZE I
THOUGHT YOU WANTED TO TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT MY FAULT-
WITNESSES YOUR LINES ARE OPEN
SO JUST PLEASE UNMUTE. THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING CHIANG MAI
NUMBER CANYON MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF THE BODY CALIFORNIA FOR THE
NATION'S LARGEST STATEWIDE
LGBTQ PRACTICAL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION. AND ONE OF THE
VERY PROUD CO SPONSOR OF THE
BILL WE THANK SENATOR LARRY FOR
HIS LONGSTANDING COMMITMENT TO
THE ISSUE AND FOR CHAMPIONING
THE BILL. WHICH WILL REALLY
DEMONSTRATE CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT FOR OLDER ADULTS
BASICALLY OLDER PEOPLE LIVING
WITH HIV BY DESIGNATING THEM AS
THE POPULATION OF GREATER
SOCIAL ME. THANK YOU MAY KNOW
JUST EARLIER THIS MONTH WE
COMMEMORATED THE FORTIETH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE FIRST
RECORDING G. SENSOR AS WELL
WHAT BECAME KNOWN AS AIDS. AND
CURRENTLY AS A DOCTOR POINTED
OUT OVER 50% OF CALIFORNIANS
LIVING WITH HIV. ARE NOW AGE
FIFTY OR OLDER THANKS TO ALL OF
THE DANCE INFANTRYMAN SINCE THE
FIRST CASES WERE RECORDED. AND
THEY SPEND THE NATION PROVIDED
FOR IN THE BILL ENSURES THAT
THE AREA AGENCIES ON AGING
WOULD BE ACTIVELY REACHING OUT
TO POPULATIONS SO THAT THEY
KNOW WHAT SERVICES AND SUPPORT
INVEST. THE SAME AS THEY DO FOR
POPULATIONS THAT ARE ALREADY
DESIGNATED- WHICH HELP THEM. TO
STAY HEALTHY AND LIVE WITH
DIGNITY. AND THE POPULATION.
CONTINUE TO BARRIER TO
SUCCESSFUL IN. EVEN ACHIEVING
HAD TO BE TECHNICAL IN- AND ALL
OF THE THEIR FAX LACK ABOUT. TO
SERVICES. THE INTERFACE
PRONOUNCED HEALTH. AND HIGHER
OF LIKE THAT. DUE TO ON GOING
STATE NOT AND I. AND LONELINESS.
SO THIS CONTINUES ALL OF THE
PROGRESS THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
MADE AND UPDATING THE LAW TO
REFLECT SCIENCE AND NOT
STATEMENT. I WILL PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR THE CELL THE STAGE
WHICH IS THE NATIONAL ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION FOR LGBTQ PLUS
OLDER ADULTS. ALONG WITH
PARTNER ORGANIZATIONS THAT
PROVIDE DIRECT SERVICES TO
LGBTQ PLUS PEOPLE AND PEOPLE
LIVING WITH HIV. MEMORY
EIGHTEEN APLE HOUSE AND THE LOS
SPONSORED AND OUR EXTENSIVE
NETWORK OF COMMUNITY ADVOCATES
AND SERVICE PROVIDERS AND
READY. TO ASSIST WITH
IMPLEMENTATION AND RESPECTFULLY.
URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THERE ANY OTHER. HI
THIS IS HEATHER ANDERSON- I AM
BUT LET'S KICK **** IN THE ASK
STANDS FOR AIDS SURVIVORS AND
WE ARE GROUP- IN SAN FRANCISCO
WE HAVE A GROUP OF PALM SPRINGS
DEDICATED TO ADVANCING
HEALTHCARE ISSUES FOR. A LONG
TERM SURVIVORS OF WHICH I AM
ONE I'M SIXTY TWO NOW AND I'VE
BEEN LIVING WITH HIV NINETEEN
EIGHTY THREE. I SEE BY AIDS
DIAGNOSIS. IN NINETEEN NINETY
FOUR. HELLO TO SIX MY DOCTOR ME
I HAD LASTED TWO YEARS TO LIVE
THE- HAVE BEEN ASKED THIS.
MOVEMENT TO HELP. EMPIRE LONG
TERM SURVIVORS IT'S ARRIVE TO
O. LIFE'S- THE PROBLEM IS THAT
WE DIDN'T IMAGINE GROWING OLD
WOULDN'T IMAGINE BEING IN OUR
SIXTIES SEVENTIES AND EIGHTIES
BECAUSE THE FIRST TWO DECADES
OF. ELIZABETHTON WE WERE ALL
DYING- WE WERE ON THE FRONT
LINES OF A NEW PANDEMIC. AND
NOW AS YOU AGING REFINED
OURSELVES THE ONE STILL ON THE
FRONT LINE OF A PANDEMIC. OF
AGING WITH HIV AND IS A VERY
UNEXPECTED THAT WAS PLANNED ON.
WE EXPECTED TO DIE NOT TO BE
AGING- SIXTY EIGHT S. B. TWO
FIVE TWO WILL WILL HELP OF
CULTURAL COMPETENCY WE NEED YOU
BECAUSE- THE THING I HEAR MOST
FROM PEOPLE. IF THEY FEEL
ISOLATED AND FORGOTTEN IT BUT
GOTTEN BY THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
WHICH THEY ARE AMBER THE
COMMUNITY AT LARGE. IT'S BUT
IT'S ALSO HAD TO DO WITH THE
FACT THAT AS AN HIV ON THE
HEADLINE. WE'VE BEEN TO
OVERTAKE BY INCONVENIENCE-THEY
LIKE TO TRAVEL THAT THAT GOES
BY THAT I GOT HERE ABOUT THE
PEER OLDER ADULTS SHOULD THE
PROJECT BE FEEL ABOUT BEING
OLDER AND GOING INTO IT WILL-
LONG TERM CARE FACILITIES AND
HAVING TO BE. WHY HAD ABOUT
THIRTY I MEAN A FEW YEARS AGO.
WE HELD A MEETING WITH BEIJING
PROVIDER AND A PROVIDER THAT
AVERAGES GOES SEVENTY FIVE
TOTAL. ALL THE AGING PROVIDERS
DIDN'T IT THEY ALSO WE DON'T
HAVE ANYBODY WITH A R. H. I. B.
R. THE PHILADELPHIA AND IT IS A
SINGLE COULD MEAN THAT THAT WAS
THE PROBLEM THAT THEY DIDN'T
KNOW THEY WERE ASKING THE RIGHT
QUESTIONS. BUT THE BIGGEST OF
WE IT IS DRIER SO. BECAUSE OF
POVERTY AND OTHER ISSUES LIKE
HELP WITH ANY ISSUES DURING
YOUR OPPORTUNITY AND- THE
COLUMBIA DO YOU HAVEN'T
MENTIONED- MOORLACH WHAT SORT
OF LIKE GINGER ROGERS AND FRED
ASTAIRE. GINGER WE DO
EVERYTHING BACKWARDS AND IN
HEELS WE'RE AG DR EXPRESS OF
THE POPULATION. AGING FASTER.
SO WE NEED TO LEGISLATURE IS A
AND TO THE LIVING WITH HIV AND
OF THE GENERATION COMING ALONG
BEHIND US BECAUSE THEY HAVE
SUPPORT. SO I URGE YOU TO PASS
LEGISLATION COMMENTARY SENATOR
LETTER FOR HIS VISION. AND BODY
OF THE MEANINGFUL PEOPLE OF
MEANINGFUL INVOLVEMENT OF
PEOPLE LIVING WITH HIV. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER ANDERSON
AND THANK YOU MISS MARTIN FOR
BOTH OF YOUR- COMMENTS-
OPERATOR LET'S GO BACK TO THE
LINES FOR A- SINCE WE HAD
ALREADY STARTED FOR CALLS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS. ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN ONE
FELL BY ZERO. AND WE'LL GO TO
LINE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS THE NEED A
STRONG GRAN AND I AM A
VOLUNTEER WITH THE A RP CAPITAL
RESPONSE TEAM AND ON BEHALF OF
THE OVER THREE MILLION.
CALIFORNIA A. R. P. MEMBERS WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE S. B. TWO
FIFTY EIGHT AND ARE
APPRECIATIVE OF SENATOR LAYERED
CONTINUAL SUPPORT OF THIS
ISSUE. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT WE WILL GO TO LINE.
NINETEEN AND FOR ANYBODY ELSE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT
FOR SB TWO FIVE EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. BY NINETEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING SHARON
TWENTY MEMBERS THE LAWNS OR ON
BEHALF OF A KILL YOU CALIFORNIA
ACTION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AND AS A FINAL REMINDER PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
EXPRESS. SUPPORT FOR SB. TWO
FIVE EIGHT. M. MISTER CARE
NOBODY ELSE IS COMING UP AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU- LET'S GO
TO ANYONE. ANY OPPOSITION
MEMBER OF ANY UP OPPOSING-
WITNESSES AVAILABLE OR ANYONE
IN QUEUE TO SPEAK. WITH IN
OPPOSE POSITION. IF NOT THEN
ANY CALLERS THE- IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL. HERE OR ON THE
PHONES OR IN ONE OF THE ROOMS.
NOPE THEN LET ME BRING IT BACK
FOR QUESTIONS TO THE COMMITTEE.
ANY QUESTIONS I'M ANYONE BETTER
CARE WHAT YOU LIKE ME TO ASK
THE PHONE LINES AT THIS TIME.
SURE THE FIRST ONE FILED BY
ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO EXPECT.
EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO SB. TWO
FIVE EIGHT. AND A MISTER NOBODY
IS KILLING UP AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU. GREAT IT SEEMS LIKE
EVERYONE'S IN LINE HERE. IN AN
AGREEMENT. I SINCE THERE'S NO
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS I DON'T
THINK. THIS BERNARD BATH YEAH I
JUST WANT TO MAKE A QUICK
COMMENT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I WAS A
BERKELEY IN THE EARLY NINETIES
AND LOST SO MANY FRIENDS TO HIV
AND AIDS AND TO KNOW THAT THERE
ARE PEOPLE WHO THAT CAN CAN AGE
WITH GRACE- WITH THIS DISEASE
IS HEART WARMINGAND THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FOR AND HAPPY
TO SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS CURRENT CENTER ALERT
FOR SO I WANT TO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS MEASURE
FORWARD- IT'S EXACTLY THIS TYPE
OF MEASURES THAT ARE FORWARD
THINKING AND BILLS THAT- WE AS
BOTH STAFF AS WELL AS I THINK
ELECTED'S LIKE TO A SEE HOW WE
CAN PROACTIVELY OFFER SUPPORT
BUT FOR THOSE OF US ORKING IN
THE AGING AND LONG TERM CARE
SPACE- WE VALUE THE WORK AND
THE DATA THAT WAS RELEASED IN
THE MASTER PLAN EARLIER IN THIS
YEAR. AND THE MOST DEVELOPED A
POLICY TO ADDRESS THE FUTURE
NEEDS AS CALIFORNIA IS
PROJECTED TO BE HOME TO ELEVEN
MILLION PEOPLE AGE SIXTY AND
OLDER BY TWENTY THIRTY THIS IS
A DOUBLING OF A DEMOGRAPHIC AND
ABOUT A LESS THAN TWENTY YEAR
TIME FRAME AND SO THESE
MEASURES LIKE THESE WILL HELP
US ADDRESS SOME OF THESE ISSUES
AS THE PUBLIC IS AGING MUCH
BETTER- SO- THE BUT THEN THE
NEEDS OF THE SIXTY PLUS
POPULATION. AND IN THE SAP
COMMUNITY THAT YOU ARE WORKING
WORKING FOR NOW ARE VERY UNIQUE
AND- FURTHER NUANCED- THAN THAN
MOST OTHERS SO- THIS MEASURE IS
AN EFFORT TO MEET THOSE NEEDS
AND I HAVE- I SUPPORT THE BILL
AND WITH THAT THERE'S A MOTION
FROM MISTRUTH THE- AND I
BELIEVE THE SECOND FOR MISS
CALDERON- AND- SO. LET'S CALL
FOR VOTE. SB TWO FIVE EIGHT THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS NAZARIAN I
NAZARIAN AYE VOEPEL THAT'S L.
I. BOERNER HORVATH WARNER
FORGOT I CALDERON CALDERON AYE
LACKEY LACKEY I RADIUS RADIUS
I'D LONGER RUBIO WHAT THE RUBIO
I. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I REALLY APPRECIATED
THANK YOU SENATOR AND WITH THAT
WE ARE ADJOURNED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BEING HERE.